out of southern mist the man of the hour
kind enough to call into the rich eyes
and show the day after his big debut on
Thursday Night Football Nick Mullens it
is a pleasure to meet you thanks for
calling in thanks for having me you bet
so how are you doing doing well
woke up and spending them one of my wife
at my apartment okay so what what was it
like for you when did you first learn
that you were starting that game last
night Nick um the really the day before
the game I wasn't exactly sure how it
was gonna go through it the week I was
preparing to start but I didn't know and
then before the game I learned I was
starting and just had to go do it so you
got an inkling of the possibility on
Wednesday but truly did not know you
were going to start until what 90
minutes before for real um no probably a
little bit before that but I was just
whenever I was told okay so you're told
and then you go out and what what did
you tell yourself as you trotted out on
the field for the first time and it was
a nationally televised game in a big Bay
Area rivalry yeah I think the biggest
thing was just focus focus on what
matters and the only thing that mattered
is how we played on the field and so
that's just what I kept telling myself
all game long
and I thought we did a great job of
staying focused all game long and I
worked out well and how did Shanahan
coach you up throughout the process Nick
what was that coach quarterback
relationship like oh he was great you
know he obviously he really didn't
change the playbook to be honest I
thought that was a cool thing you know
he let me go command offense um gave me
a lot of freedom let me make good
decisions put me in good positions 2:16
so he definitely called a great game and
let me have success when you say give
him freedom what what sort of freedom
you talking about I just didn't alter
the playbook and I was very appreciative
of that you know he is he had confidence
that under this system when I was ready
to operate and that was so I definitely
appreciate him and believe in a loop did
you check out of a play did you
did you go a little Omaha on him last
night oh no nothing nothing too crazy so
got the play run the play and then you
were successful more more often than not
what was your phone like when you got
back to it last night oh it was it was
pretty crowded for sure I have a lot of
people back home that support me and so
that was pretty cool to see I haven't
gone all the way through and I don't
know if I will but definitely appreciate
all the support that I've got the whole
49 organizations got none these past 24
hours so what was the number of texts
was the number all 500 come on whoa five
you had 500 texts on your phone when you
got back to it after Thursday Night
Football
oh yeah I did you're a popular guy Nick
Mullens you are a popular guy yes I
guess so fantastic okay I noticed that
you got emotional with Erin Andrews
afterwards what we what was going
through your temples when you were
talking postgame last night on file it
really just I was glad we got the win
it's everything that we worked for the
seasons been a grind so far and so just
the way we work to get this win I was a
big moment for 13 so I was just really
excited we got the one but nothing
personal about whatever journey you've
taken
that's that struck me as much as a team
person that you clearly are and your
teammates reaction to your success shows
that but what nothing personal was going
through your mind as you realized you'd
threw three touchdowns in a big victory
for the 49ers on national television I
think the biggest personal thing for me
was just the fact that I had gotten to
the 49ers and wanted to learn the system
as much as I could and I had plenty of
time to do that on the practice squad
and things like that and so it's just a
matter of time before I got my
opportunity and that's what I kept
thinking after the game Nick Mullens
here on the Rich Eisen show after
throwing for three touchdowns in his NFL
debut passer rating just a little shy of
a buck fifty two right here on the Rich
Eisen show what was your draft day like
Nick
by Jeff day the 49ers from I only treat
pre job visit I thought that I would get
an opportunity and then I fell but I
didn't know how long it was last it
would last and it was just kind of all
on me to see how far I could go
so I had a couple small three agent
offers but the 49ers like me from the
start
and I have the most respect for them for
finding me and liking me the most and so
they gave me a call it on the sixth
round and then I just kind of knew I was
going to sign with them so did you think
that you might get a call from the 49ers
on draft day I'm just wondering what it
was like for you to to have that
experience yeah I think my expectations
were to sign as a free agent and if I
got drafted it would be a really cool
surprise you know so just had to have
some what realistic expectations I guess
you would say and but I was just
thankful for any opportunity I could get
and so what's your relationship like
with Favre who called in last night that
was a neat moment as well on the NFL
Network I think I bet your Mariucci
hooked that one up being on the set what
was that like yeah yeah that was a
pretty cool pretty cool moment um you
know he's obviously a Southern Miss alum
too and we do a good job of keeping in
touch and just supporting the Golden
Eagle family when we can he came around
a couple of times a year in college and
so it was always cool to hear his
stories and learn from him and just
appreciate his wisdom it's not why you
wear for number four not really to be
honest I was number one in pre-season
and they had a couple numbers and four
was just the best option and it was just
a cool coincidence that it's four and
four uh yeah it's cool court said well
I'm very glad that you're for your first
game experience was not Favre like are
you you're aware what his first pass
attempt was like in the National
Football League right Nick believe so it
was a pick six and do you know do you
know completing the Favre trivia portion
of our interview here the first person
he completed a pass to in his career do
you know what that person is I do not
know himself you
tapped back to him unbelievable
overstock yeah but I'll tell you what
not nearly as impressive as three
touchdowns I mean is this is this the
stuff of dreams I'm serious like I know
the answer to it but I'm wondering if
this is the stuff that you dreamt about
trying to get to the NFL in your journey
Nick oh yes sir it is because I never
knew how far my opportunity would go so
I'm for it to come to this it's been
pretty cool but it's obviously only one
game at the same time so as a big-time
win yeah you could say that dreams came
true but there's a lot more stuff that
um I'd like for this team to accomplish
and what is it what did it feel for you
I know what it felt like for me to watch
it Nick your teammates reacting to your
success oh that's why you play the game
I said that after the game to celebrate
with your teammates
you know we all played great offense
defense special teams we had very little
penalties no turnovers and displayed as
a great collective team win and that's
what I was most proud of after the game
is we play like that and it's gonna lead
a lot more wins so that was pretty cool
to see okay so what's the rest of your
Friday looking like Nick Mullens after
your big your big win I know you're
saying you're there with your wife right
you don't have kids yet right no sir I
don't I don't want to rush it yet okay
did I did I hear a dog in the background
oh you did sorry no it's okay don't Nick
you have no idea what we've heard in the
background and they hear you've been the
a in the history of this show what what
what dog do you have have a red golden
doodle okay red Goldendoodle is is it
named Favre is did you name that no sir
no sir that what's your dog's name my
dog's name is scout scout your wife
named the dog Nick she did yeah scope
Brockman that's a great line you said am
i you're say it yourself Nick you're
gonna have to change it to starter now
now that you're the starter Scout team
is starter name it starter and are you
aware that you got verified on Twitter
during your performance Nick oh yes sir
that's what they notify the rest of the
year okay
well you certainly are blue checkmark
verified in the National Football League
after last night Nick thanks for calling
in I know again like I said it's just
one game and you hope to have many more
like that but it was just amazing to to
witness and I honestly did not know what
to expect from you and you exceeded it
so congratulations on that
well thank you you bet you bet so you're
gonna go to out to lunch dinner what do
you got on Friday now what do you got
now uh yeah probably so just grab some
lunch and head up to the facility at
some point and just go along a little
weekend okay now go for it maybe we'll
see out there next Sunday we'll check it
out all right good deal
Thanks thanks for calling and that's
Nick Mullens at Nick Mullens on Twitter
how many of followers does he have he's
currently at twenty seven point six
thousand do we know what he was lying
right I don't know that the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience